yo 98.3 man ready set radio bootleg cab
live in studio right now we got my dude
we have got kendrick lamar what's
popping yes sir man first things first i
cannot wait till november 16th though
you got powerhouse you're gonna be
coming out here yeah it's gonna be crazy
it's gonna be crazy crazy yeah that uh
the the big performance that um everyone
was talking about last year is when you
know you you had performed in l.a
and the game and a lot of the other west
coast all-stars like they came out and
officially passed you the torch and you
you know you had cried on stage man
there's a crying
yeah it's a little emotional yeah it was
a fun moment too great moment indeed man
so we can't wait man november 16th is
going to be special as well um
i cannot wait for the new album it's
finally coming october 22nd yeah good
kid mad city yes sir i feel like i've
been waiting for the cd forever man we
go way back man yeah we do man we do
it's crazy it is crazy man we both we
both doing better right now yeah exactly
exactly hey um with the album uh we've
been playing like i've been playing the
compton joint on on the underground
hip-hop show and we've been playing it
during my afternoon show um what is the
direction of the album i mean section 80
i felt like came out of nowhere and it
sounded like something i i guess nothing
really you know what i'm saying is are
you kind of you know picking up from
from where section 80 left off on the
new album um somewhat as far as have an
original sound yeah def definitely
definitely it don't sound like nothing
else um i always want to keep that
original originality and um
really i just took took pieces from
section 8 that i liked the most so you
will have a lot of storytelling that's
what's up i would say
yeah i would say that the artwork for
the album is almost like tells a little
bit of a story yeah yeah uh is that the
minivan on the deluxe edition is that
the minivan your mom's minivan who knows
who knows who knows gotta check that out
you gotta you gotta you gotta get it i'm
sure you you don't hold me so i can tell
you off here okay okay so off air
you know several things but you know you
you list it out from top top to bottom
one through 12. you'll find out then you
get to understand it there it is man
there it is um let's talk about the the
whole entire tde camp you guys have had
a very crazy
2012 2011 it just seems like you guys
are kind of changing hip hop with with
your sound right now um
you know when it comes to absol
schoolboy q
uh j rock these guys
what's it been like from your
perspective for for a while because i
remember when i first heard of you or k
dot and j rock was like the guy who was
really you know heading to camp and what
has it been like to really see the
growth of each each one of them dudes
you know what i'm saying those are your
brothers you know what you're saying and
they all have their own fan bases now
rightfully yeah that's that's the great
thing about it and um that's how we
always want to play off of it you know
because when you look at
um
artists that's at the forefront you know
of the labels you always have you know
the cats behind them and they always get
held in in this position of just being
you know behind that major artist i
never wanted that we never wanted that
we wanted everybody to solidify
themselves you know as their own entity
you know so you have schoolboy q with
his you know core base j-rock absolutely
right puffy you know and it's a great
feeling because at the end of the day we
all come together as one unit you know
they inspire me you know they go hard it
makes me want to get in there and go
even more hard and i'm sure i do the
same for them like a friendly
competition yeah definitely definitely
definitely what was it like uh recording
the bt cipher with
40 exactly snoop all them guys you know
what what was that like recording
session like yeah that was crazy um i
didn't even know i was doing it till the
day of really yeah that morning um
because i did it the year before so i
you know i didn't assume i was gonna be
on it but they called me the day of said
that i was in l.a and um it was it was a
surreal moment you know they know you
got e40 quick quick quick
box snoop
like exhibit yeah you know and me and yg
the young bucks in the game following up
continuing that that legacy it's a great
feeling indeed man cali it seems like
right now like you mentioned just
mentioned yg
cali's really like i want to say
refreshing what california hip-hop
sounds like yeah yourself you got your
own sound and you got yg yeah tyga these
dudes it's like almost
before cali was really known for like i
want to say like gangster hip-hop really
you know what i'm saying right nowadays
it seems like you guys yourself and and
everybody else really kind of pushing
more
as far as those other dudes pushing more
party fun music yeah yourself more
conscious you know real hip-hop type
stuff
um the evolution of california hip-hop
man i mean do you feel like you know you
you kind of were the torch holder and
changing kind of the direction of it um
i wasn't a torture holder i feel like
this generation just the generation was
in general you know you have these kids
growing up
and um
we still have the same antics of you
know as far as the game culture and the
lifestyle and we're gonna go yeah that's
never gonna leave but at the same time
we have a a story that we want to tell
now you know and it's just a little bit
you know different from what you know
older cats were saying in the 90s you
know so you have these different um
versions of music of great music and
great quality sound it's just a new feel
and you know people is receptive to it
so we just continuing to do us that's
what's up man how did you uh link up
with jess blaze was that the compton
record is bananas appreciate it it is
bananas and i saw i i just i was i was
on my phone and i saw on rap radar said
kendrick featuring dr dre produced by
just blaze and i was like whoa i gotta
get home and listen to this yes sir
were you guys in studio together was it
an mp3 sent over you know what i'm
saying now we was in the studio we was
in the studio and um
dre had to be playing just blaze was in
there dre had to be playing i heard a
couple of drake vocals on it and i just
immediately just started writing that
was the first session i had with dre
really yeah it's my first time meeting
him wow and everything and uh
jessica came through and um that beat
was zoned so was that the first song
that you wrote to while dreaming was
around so that's my first song that was
my first time meaning my first time
writing wow on the record with dre that
was like almost um
i would like to say that was the um that
was the quiz right there right that's
right
he's putting me to the top
he put me to the test that's why this
song is so special and that's one of the
reasons why it's the last song on there
how nervous were you writing that first
verse crazy brian compton that's exact
verse i wasn't nervous i was more
excited because i felt like that's my
shot
i got to improve yeah yeah this i felt
like all them years of writing them
wraps in in that kitchen in my mom's
kitchen going back and forth to studio
sessions
all that built up to that very moment of
writing that song compton and the first
time being dre and that song's so
special man that yeah now now it's like
i'll listen to it a different way oh
yeah and when you hit the album you
would listen to it a different way
that's what's up from where's where it's
formatted and where it's placed
hey why didn't we ever get a video for
for the recipe yeah yeah um the crazy
thing about that we had two versions we
had that version that didn't come out
okay
and we had the um coachella and we just
made the decision we want to make it
feel like
that point in time to capture that time
10 years down the line i'll be able to
look back and know i wrote the song
recipe
when coachella was coming you know and
be able to look at it like that and it
just felt more organic and more real
that's what's up man yes what's up hey i
want to talk to you about your accent
you have in in cartoons and cereal and
uh yeah even a little bit on uh swimming
pools yeah uh
what's up with the accent man i know
some people like it some people don't
like it i'm a fan i mean i'm just a fan
i accent i don't know i want to say the
accent when you change up the picture
your voice you know oh well that's
something that me and my girl anna wise
does on sunday moon just a new sound
being creative just being creative yeah
it's nothing there it is i mean over the
top crazy there it is hey uh
after
tuesday october 22nd uh when everyone
finally hears the debut album from
that's a monday medal that's a monday
okay
so monday october 22nd everyone's going
to finally hear this album it's probably
to me the most anticipated album of the
year yeah um what do you want people to
be you know what do you want people to
say about the album you know 24 hours
after i mean what do i want to be a
classic yeah um 10 years down the line
to be a classic i hate calling things
classic now i want to you know when it
lasts
10 years and people are saying yo i'm
still listening to this that's when it's
a classic right now it's it's a great
great great great great great album
and um
24 hours i want people to say you know
he lived up to the expectations like yo
i'm sure
it's real oh yeah
yeah it definitely is
it is man yeah man cause i'm not i'm not
gonna slight nothing man i'm putting a
lot a lot of time you know in the studio
i know a lot of people probably just
hear me when they seen
you know dre got in the backing of it
but before that it's been a lot of time
man in that studio and being a student
of the game and perfecting craft and and
just honoring the art you know of
hip-hop and that's what i'm putting in
this in this album and um i feel like
it's not been haven't been done in a
long time you know as far as far as
what i'm talking about and something
cohesive and some of this
conceptually um
a bulk as far as art you know hip-hop
and
i'm putting that on the pedestal you
know just like you know the people my
people that listen to me you know they
got high expectations but i always had
them high expectations for myself there
it is man kendrick lamar can't wait for
the album we're going to see you on
stage you're one of the uh illest
performers i've seen dog you you bring
it down live man appreciate it man i
seen you like real early and then i i
saw you in vegas remember remember that
ratchet ass showing vegas
all messed up see that's why people
don't be people don't be knowing stuff
like that man it's a whole lot of stuff
you got to go through man you remember
that was like like 50 people in there
yeah but you killed it though yeah man
and the sound was terrible sound was
terrible yeah man but i love the moments
though because yeah
it creates memories man and you know it
just shows growth dawg so you know i
can't wait for powerhouse it's gonna be
crazy the album coming out yeah um man
thank you thank you fans perspective
thank you for for putting out the music
i do appreciate you refreshes the
culture homie yes sir there it is man
it's ready set radio power 98.3 kendrick
lamar bang
bootleg
[__] [__]